élu d'opposition de 2007 à 2014 derrière
sandrine grand gang est membre
associatif de la commune pierre déjean a
été désigné comme tête de liste pour
montigny solidarité 2020 avec une
campagne orienté sur trois axes
principaux le premier et leur jus du
premier parce qu'il faut commencer par à
mais ils sont tous ceux équivalent en
valeur c'est la démocratie locale
le second c'est l'écologie et le
troisième c'est la solidarité chine
membre du parti de gauche pierre déjean
rassemble derrière lui des colistiers de
différents partis ou sans étiquette mais
avec cette forte volonté de se
revendiquer de gauche avec ses valeurs
aucune investiture deux parties demandé
mais les soutiens seront bien accueillis
on considère qu'aujourd'hui la gauche
elle a des valeurs à la des valeurs
fondamentales des valeurs de fraternité
et valeurs d'humanisme des valeurs de
solidarité et que ce sont ces valeurs-là
que l'on veut clairement exprimée par
rapport à la population qu'il n'y ait
connu aucune ambiguïté par rapport à
cela
je pense que je serais quand même pas
parti sur une liste flou que j'utilise
le terme exprès moi je veux
effectivement que la politique qui soit
menée sur une politique de gauche pour
faire du social rénovation des maisons
de quartier gratuité des transports est
mise en place d'un guichet unique sont
des propositions de cette liste beaucoup
de citoyens un moment donné se trouve
confronté à un problème et ne savent pas
à qui s'adresser
donc ce que nous envisagions c'est de
mettre à la disposition ce qu'on appelle
le guichet unique et qui permettra de
venir
et là nous aurons des agents municipaux
qui vont orienter les 39 noms ne sont
pas encore réunies mais la tête de liste
se montre confiante